mast wearing sociopaths are never a good
thing in westeros but what makes a crab
feeder such a terrifying threat
chock full of the politics and drama
that make game of thrones popular house
of the dragon fills in the gaps of
westerosi history during the waning
period of targaryen rule
of course by the time game of thrones
rolls around the targaryens are all but
extinct but in the prequel they and
various aristocratic families of old
valyria still maintain tenuous control
over what would eventually be known as
the seven kingdoms however there's
definitely a conflict brewing on the
horizon game of thrones has its fair
share of heroes and villains and even
more characters that happily straddle
the line between while house of the
dragon is still at the very beginning of
its arc it's already quite clear that
the show follows the general vibe of the
original as such there's reason to
believe that several backstabbing
double-crossing game of thrones
archetypes will eventually emerge as
well as a visually captivating villain
to unite at least some of them against
indeed episode 2 appears to deliver on
both fronts first lord cordless valarian
grows weary of king viserys and the
small council's apathy toward the
growing threats in the stepstones when
the king is reluctant to send forces
believing that doing so would cause open
warfare corless aligns himself with the
exile damon targaryen the episode also
gives us a glimpse at the threat the
master of boats is so concerned about a
monstrous masked figure called the crab
feeder and the crab themed torture that
appears to give him his name but who is
this character why are they important
and could they potentially provide a
night king style threat to westeros
let's find out it's important to note
that house of the dragon is based on
george rr martin's prequel book fire and
blood as such even dedicated fans have
much less written story to draw from
than they had in game of thrones even so
the mass purveyor of crap themed
brutality we see in the closing moments
of episode 2 is almost certainly none
other than cragus drejar in fact corliss
has already explicitly confirmed this
back in episode one
a man called cragus drejar has styled
himself the prince admiral of this
triarchy
they call him the crab feeder if the
amassed byrne drajar is anything like
the rather more ordinary looking version
in the source material he's about to
become a pretty major player in the
series that's because he has the
leadership of mir lis and tiros
collectively known as the triarchy now
that he has the stepstones he's a force
to be reckoned with at sea as well and
one that lord corliss would clearly
prefer to avoid dealing with in any
capacity that doesn't involve open
warfare much like his book counterpart
the show's cragus is known as the crab
peter due to his peculiar tendency to
leave his helpless enemies tied to
debris on low tide turning their drowned
flesh into a crab banquet considering
the location of the step zones and the
apprehensive views of lord corliss the
area this ominous figure is now holding
as an important shipping lane the crab
feeder's presence in the step stones
will no doubt cause some serious
disruptions to corliss's business which
is why he's attempting to lure daemon
into this conflict needless to say
drejar will certainly be an important
player in the upcoming episodes of house
of the dragon however it remains to be
seen whether he has the might to stand
against dragons
[Music]